ein busfahrer schmeißt zwei schüler aus
dem schulbus weil sie ihre corona masken
nicht tragen wollten einen zehnjährigen
und 1 12 jährigen das ist jetzt passiert
in mecklenburg vorpommern bei neukloster
in der nähe von wismar so drastisch
setzt ein busfahrer dort bei kindern die
masken pflicht durch die fliegen einfach
raus aus dem bus müssen nach hause
laufen und das während die anderen sich
längst von der maske befreit haben sie
wissen scholz & harbeck im
regierungsflieger dort im
regierungsflieger gilt längst keine
masken pflicht mehr für die gelten
sonderregeln extrawürste sagen jetzt
viele deutsche wie kann das sein wie
kann einerseits die masken pflicht bei
uns immer noch mit ganzer härte
durchgesetzt werden kinder die aus dem
schulbus rausfliegen und dann alleine
laufen müssen und die regierung selbst
hat sich von diesen regeln längst
befreit links unser leben kinder die aus
dem schulbus rausfliegen und rechts das
regierungs leben das leben im
regierungsflieger masken frei längst das
passt nicht zusammen oder olaf scholz
was sagt der kanzler jetzt dazu zu
dieser riesen diskussion erst das gerade
gefragt worden auf seiner kanadareise
und hat dann diesen scholz satz gesagt
gibt klare regeln was flugbereitschaft
betrifft ja der kanzler also hält sich
einfach an die regeln sagt er aber er
geht gar nicht ein auf diese
ungerechtigkeit hier die harten regeln
für uns alle und auf der anderen seite
die masken freiheit im flieger da
scheint die regierung gar nicht um zu
treiben im gegenteil sie will noch einen
oben draufsetzen heute hier am
kabinettstisch obwohl scholz & harbeck
längst masken frei fliegen wollen sie
jetzt gleich im kabinett heute vormittag
eine noch härtere masken pflicht dem
flieger für uns alle beschließen
medizinische masken sollen dann nicht
mehr ausreichen es muss künftig die ft2
maske im flugzeug seien keine masken
pflicht für kanzler und minister im
flieger noch härtere masken pflicht für
uns also
[Musik]